[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler ordinateur
juste là qu'on va parler du swift 7,2
acer qui arrivé il ya quelques jours on
va pouvoir en apprendre davantage sur
lui windows 10 intel core i7 1 8 gigas
de ram
lp ddr3 va y avoir plein de trucs cool
avoir sur cette bécane mais la première
chose qu'on va l'ouvrir
[Musique]
ouverture on à la première partie ici
premiers rushes pour urs pense l'ordi
deuxième partie blog de charge
voyons voir directement là où incroyable
là je le france au bout du doigt vous
voyez pas mais en prenant comme ça je me
rends compte de l'épaisseur il est
extrêmement fin je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte mais la finesse je pose au
dessus mon iphone 10 avec sa coque il
plus vite leur ordinateur pour attirer
les performances après et on verra s'il
est à la hauteur de la finesse de cette
bécane
c'est vraiment magnifique ensuite à
l'intérieur ça c'est la housse pour le
transporter super classe aimanté la
petite pochette pour ranger alors ce qui
est complètement dingue c'est vraiment
simple que vous avez un produit qui est
extrêmement fin et là vous avez un truc
qui tout petit vous le prenez vous le
glisse et de danse justice et là tu te
dis qu'il est dans son ordinateur
portable
incroyable ensuite à l'intérieur on a
ici un guide de démarrage
le guide rapide windows 10 qui est là
avec toutes les informations à
l'intérieur qu'est ce qu'on a ici ça me
tient basser avec de l'usb du l'usb type
c est ça ça donne du hdmi
parce que du fait de l'épaisseur c'est
vrai que les connectiques ici c'est pas
complètement dingue on a quoi usb tilt
c'est usb type s'est prise jack lang à
la place pour poser une petite carte sim
et ça croyez moi avoir la 4g là dessus
c'est vraiment vraiment bien pour avoir
internet partout lors tous vos
déplacements c'est vraiment super le
bouton pour l'allumer donc forcément on
n'a pas grand chose donc si on veut on a
ici le petit à petit elle va certes on
branche la en usb type c est là on
récupère de la connectique ça c'est cool
tout bien penser ensuite de l'autre côté
si on a ici le bloc charge
on a ici complètement agréablement
surpris par l'épaisseur de la bécane
c'est vraiment incroyable sa cote est
hyper minimaliste facile emmener avec
soi
le truc complètement ouf la finesse de
l'ordinateur sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte
mais la finesse elle est complètement
ouf la bécane est vraiment incroyable
il fait 8,90
mm d'épaisseur c'est complètement ouf
donc ce que je vous propose c'est que à
partir de maintenant je prenne quelques
jours pour bien le tester vient de
prendre en main bien le découvrir voir
comment ils fonctionnent sur le principe
je trouve en tout cas vraiment super
sympa j'adore le côté hyper compact du
switch de 7 donc je vais tester pendant
quelques jours donc faire un clap de fin
pour aujourd'hui et on se retrouve
d'ici quelques jours pour reparler du
suisse de cette arrivée
ça fait quelques jours que je teste la
soulte 7,2 acer et je vais maintenant
vous donner mon verdict vous dire ce que
j'en pense elle a des points très
positifs aussi quelques points négatifs
messager vous détailler petit aparté
pour tous ceux qui me disent toutes
celles qui le disent un commentaire qui
a des problèmes avec la mise au point la
caméra j'ai changé quelques paramètres
donc dites moi en commentaire si ça va
mieux si vous trouvez que la mise au
point se fait mieux si ça décroche mois
n'hésitez pas de marquer ça à partir de
maintenant j'ai tourné le dos il ya
quelques jours on pouvait marquer tout
ça en commentaire j'espère que ça ira
mieux
on y va avec la swift celle de nasser on
est dans l'ultra portable on est
vraiment dans un ordi dans un ordi
portable vraiment compact et c'est
vraiment l'adn de ce produit et c'est ça
qui le différencie un petit peu de la
concurrence
niveau design il a vraiment un look qui
est très premium et l'intérêt c'est
effectivement qu'il est fabriqué avec un
châssis en aluminium l'aluminium c'est
léger donc du coup forcément ça lui
apportent de la légèreté temps normal
acer nous livre en 2018 un swift cette
revue corrigée
toujours aussi bien c'est donc un
ultraportable signataires qui est
extrêmement réussite par rapport à la
version précédente en plus ce qui est
vraiment bien c'est la performance on a
un intel core i7 7 y 75 pour être très
précis cadencé à 1,3 ghz 8 gigas de ram
lp ddr3 et en puissant ssd de 512 giga
alors que leurs précédentes n'avaient
qu'un ssd de 256 go ce qui était déjà
plutôt pas mal
il a un chipset graphique intel hd
graphics 620 pour intéressant sur cette
machine c'est son écran vous avez un
écran qui est bien évidemment
complètement tactile
vous avez aussi un très grand trackpad à
pour venir ici naviguer ça s'est
vraiment bien ça gâche absolument pas le
plaisir point qui est aussi super le
clavier est rétro éclairé ce qui n'était
pas le cas avant à noter que vous avez
un écran qui est plus grande que leur
seul précédent vous aviez un 13 pouces
avant là vous avez un 14 pouces 1920 par
1080 c'est une dali ps au format 16/9
noter que vous avez un verre gorilla
glass gros point positif vous avez
vraiment une excellente luminosité et
des contrastes sont très bien rendus pas
de cap cas là dessus mais par contre ça
fait vraiment bien à faire j'adore le
clavier ce trou extrêmement bien réussie
vous avez ici sur côté un capteur
d'empreintes digitales convenir
déverrouiller très facilement votre ordi
ça c'est vraiment cool les touches sont
vraiment bien se passer par rapport à la
version antérieure le fait d'avoir
quatre tirages qui importe vraiment un
gros
gros plus et une fois de plus le
trackpad qui est vraiment très très
grand vous confère vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de confort
pour pouvoir naviguer ça aussi c'est top
lazio n'est pas du tout sur des
ordinateurs qui vont pouvoir se
retourner
mettre à l'envers mettre en mode
tablette mais par contre ce qui est très
drôle et ce café à sarlat dessus vous
pouvez complètement le mettre à plat
si vous le souhaitez je sais pas ce que
vous allez en faire comme ça mais si
vous voulez vous pouvez le faire
du point de vue de l'audio vous avez des
hauts parleurs qui situent juste là en
dessous un de ce côté et un de l'autre
côté ce qui fait qu'en fonction de la
manière dont vous allez le posez vous
allez avoir un son qui va être plus ou
moins étouffée lorsque vous le posez sur
une surface complètement plat ça marche
parfaitement bien mais si vous le posez
par exemple sur vos genoux en fonction
de l'endroit où ça va venir appuyer vous
venir étouffer un peu les haut parleurs
et ça ça peut être un petit point de
regrets à côté de ça lo'jo fonctionne
plutôt pas mal le duo est pas mal mais
il manque un tout petit peu de puissance
est ce que ça devienne la position des
haut parleurs est ce que le fait de
mettre à l'avant sont rapportés un
regain de puissance c'est pas trop sinon
le spectre audio est plutôt bien assez
bien respectés s'est pas non plus criard
forcément et je vous le dis une fois de
plus en fonction de la position
ça peut être aussi un petit peu
problématique à côté de ça lorsque vous
écouter au casque leçon juste démentiel
très belle basse très beau grave c'est
ouf ici même il ya une qualité audio qui
est vraiment là des graphes sont
vraiment présent le spectre audio est
vraiment top
et rien que pour ça je vous le
recommande autre point qui est
absolument génial là dessus c'est que
vous n'avez absolument aucun bruit
faut dire qu'à pas de ventilateur il y
en a absolument pas donc du coup pas de
ventilateur qui va faire du bruit
un refroidissement passif fort produit
vraiment bien en terme de choc il va
chauffer légèrement plus par ici
mais une fois de plus c'est vraiment son
utilisation prolongée si vous m'aidez
quelque chose d'un petit peu gourmand
mais à côté de ça sinon en termes de
dissipation de chaleur
c'est vraiment bien et surtout un swift
celle complètement silencieux top
vous avez un windows dix professionnels
vous pouvez installer bien évidemment
tous vos logiciels dessus couplé avec un
écran tactile avec une machine et que 8
gigas de ram et un intel core i7 ça
fonctionne merveilleusement bien
pour aussi qui vraiment cool cette
machine préfère du
montage vidéo sans aucun problème avec 8
gigas de ram ça fonctionnera vous
pourrez monter en full hd
ici pas d'écran 4 k néanmoins pour
toutes vos utilisations ça fonctionnera
très très très bien quoique extrêmement
apprécié sur cette machine aussi c'est
l'autonomie
vous avez une autonomie annoncée de 10
heures moi je les fais tourner
absolument fausse aucun problème entre 9
à 10 heures ça dépend bien évidemment ce
qu'on va faire tourner dessus
si c'est uniquement de la vidéo sur un
match des programmes un peu plus grand
si vous faites du montage vidéo
forcément ça va pédaler davantage vous
serez pas du tout aux 10 heures nous et
quand même croire utilisé suffisamment
longtemps pour faire ce que vous avez à
faire donc de ce point de vue là c'est
vraiment bête moi ce que j'aime beaucoup
sur cette swift c'est d'la d'acer
version 2018 ces cas une évolution par
rapport aux modèles d'avant par rapport
au swift le sait qu'on peut retrouver
les années précédentes l'écran est un
peu plus grands on reste toujours sur du
full hd toujours très épais on a rajouté
100 g
mais globalement ça change pas grand
chose on passe d'un intel core i5 intel
core i7 toujours 8 giga drame ça c'est
plutôt cool on a un ssd qui est plus
grands spas de 256 à 512 donc ça aussi
c'est une vraie avancée mais surtout ce
que j'aille là dessus c'est vraiment
l'ultra portabilité et on voit qu'on est
en concurrence sur un produit comme ça
avec des macbook d'apple et surtout avec
des ordinateurs ultra ultra portable
mais qui par contre on fait absolument
aucune concession sur la puissance sur
l'inter formant donc vous avez une
machine que vous pouvez ranger très
facilement dans n'importe quelle poche
est n'importe quel sac alone à porte ou
qui vous prendra absolument pas de place
avec de la puissance de la performance
un windows 10 un écran rétro éclairé qui
n'étaient pas là avant ça c'est cool
vous pouvez faire tourner des jeux en 3d
ça fonctionnera du montage vidéo ça ira
très bien alors qu'avant j'étais quand
même un petit peu plus limites
enfin une machine qui est vraiment
extrêmement polyvalente très facile à
porter et ça c'est vraiment le très très
gros point fort maintenant le point peu
négative de cette machine
s'il peut y avoir un point négatif c'est
déjà la présence je médite à l'heure des
haut parleurs stéréo à l'arrière parce
qu'en fonction de la surface en cas vous
avez posé ça va pas être terrible
terrible et autres points que j'aime un
petit peu moins c'est cette grande barre
en bas de l'écran votre écran il vient
jusque là et là vous avez tout ce grand
pavé noir en bas c'est un peu moins joli
point aussi positif vous avez la
présence d'une webcam en bas bon ça
c'est pas mal
cette grande bordure en bas je suis pas
hyper hyper hyper fan je trouve que sur
un écran comme ça au final ça vous fait
quelque chose de hyper hyper massif le
haut et très fin les côtés sont très
fins et en bas vous avez la très grosse
bordure est ce qu'il serait pas possible
la serre de garder un écran de 14 pouces
mais diminuent un petit peu la taille du
châssis ici quitte à rogner un petit peu
sur le bas sur cette partie là c'est
parti là je sais pas en tout cas je
trouve vraiment vraiment très très bien
réussi d'un point de vue esthétique
vraiment excellente machine très très
fine une fois de plus donc ça s'est
vraiment bien et connaît-il maintenant
en termes de tarifs
alors forcément par rapport au swift
c'est que vous pouviez trouver avant il
ya forcément être plus cher c'est un
produit que vous avez trouvé aux
alentours des 1700 euros d'ailleurs si
vous intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en
bas dans la description alors on va
tester beaucoup d'ordinateurs portables
vous savez on parle beaucoup de
smartphones deux mondes connectés
d'ordinateurs portables parce que je
trouve ça super intéressant ça fait
partie des objets technologiques qu'on a
tous avec nous que ce soit à titre perso
ou ati pro donc c'est plutôt cool de s'y
trouve un peu la bonne solution
la bonne machine la bonne connectique la
bonne ce sens qu'un bras tout ça tout ça
donc je vous invite à faire deux choses
la toute première c'est de me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
que ce que vous pensez de ce swift celle
d'acer version 2018 est-ce que vous avez
cette version de 2018 est ce que vous
l'avez déjà acheté est ce que vous avez
la version 2010 est est ce que vous avez
d'autres produits de acer mark et moi
tout ça directement bas en commentaire
et la deuxième chose que je vous invite
à faire c'est pour rester connectés et
connaître toute l'actualité c'est bien
évidemment à vous abonner et à rester
connectés d'ici là soyez sages vous
embrasse
[Musique]